Max Weber is one of the philosophers
best able to explain to us the peculiar
economic system we live within called
capitalism born in err foot in Germany
in 1864 Weber grew up to see his country
convulsed by the dramatic changes of the
Industrial Revolution cities were
exploding in size vast companies were
forming a new managerial elite was
replacing the old aristocracy Weber
spent his life analyzing these changes
and he developed some key ideas with
which we can better understand the
workings and future of capitalism
the standard view is that capitalism
began as a result of developments in
technology especially steam power but
Weber proposed something more
interesting that what actually made
capitalism possible was a set of ideas
and in particular religious ideas and
not just any religious ideas capitalism
was created by Protestantism
specifically Calvinism in his great work
the Protestant ethic and the spirit of
capitalism published in 1905 weber laid
out some of the reasons why he believed
protestant christianity had been so
crucial to capitalism in vapers analysis
catholics have it relatively easy
they're able to confess their
transgressions at regular intervals and
can be cleansed by priests but no such
purifications are available to
protestants who believe that only God is
able to forgive anyone and he won't make
his intentions known until the day of
judgment until then
Weber alleged Protestants are left with
heightened feelings of anxiety as well
as lifelong guilty desires to prove
their virtue to a severe all-seeing but
silent God
in Weber XY's Protestant feelings of
guilt were diverted into an obsession
with hard work this was what he called
the Protestant work ethic the sins of
Adam could only be expunged through
constant toil not coincidentally there
were far fewer festivals and days of
rest in Protestantism God didn't like
time off
Catholics had limited their conception
of holy work to the activities of
priests monks and nuns but now
Protestants declared that work of any
kind could be done in the name of God
even jobs like being a baker or an
accountant this lent new moral energy
and earnestness to all branches of
professional life
in Catholic countries the family was and
often still is everything reporte sance
took a less benevolent view of family
the family could be a haven for selfish
and egoistic motives for early
Protestants one was meant to direct one
selfless energies to the community as a
whole the public realm where everyone
deserved fairness and dignity
Protestantism and eventually scientific
capitalism turned its back on miracles
Weber called this the disenchantment of
the world so prosperity wasn't to be
thought of as something mysteriously
ordained by God it could only be the
result of thinking methodically acting
honestly and working industriously and
sensibly over many years without a
belief in miracles people turned to
science for explanations and changes
which encouraged scientific
investigation and discovery and
eventually technological booms taken
together these five factors created in
Weber XY's
the crucial catalytic ingredients for
capitalism to take hold
Marx had argued that religion was the
opium of the masses a drug that induced
passive acceptance of the horrors of
capitalism but Weber turned this dictum
on its head people didn't tolerate
capitalism because of religion they only
became capitalists as a result of their
religion
there are about 35 countries where
capitalism is now well developed it
probably works best in Germany where
Weber first observed it but in the
remaining hundred sixty-one nations it
arguably isn't working very well at all
this is a source of much puzzlement and
distress billions of dollars in aid to
transferred every year from the rich to
the poor parts of the world but a ver
Berrien analysis tells us that these
materialist interventions will never
work because the problem isn't really a
material one to begin with
instead certain countries for weber fail
to succeed at capitalism because they
don't feel anxious and guilty enough
they trust too much in miracles
they'd like to celebrate now rather than
invest in tomorrow and their members
feel it's acceptable to steal from the
community in order to enrich their
families favouring the clan over the
nation today weber would cancel those
who wish to spread capitalism to
concentrate on our equivalent of
religion culture it's a nation's
attitudes hopes and a sense of what life
is about
that produces an economy that either
flourishes or flounders to reduce
poverty Weber would say one has to start
at the level of ideas what the World
Bank and the IMF should be giving
sub-saharan Africa is not in a verb
Arian analysis money and technology but
a new outlook the decisive question for
an economy should not be what the rate
of inflation is but what's on TV tonight
Weber was writing in an age of
revolution he too wanted things to
change but he believed that one first
had to work at how political power
operated Weber believed that humanity
had gone through three distinct types of
power the older societies operated
according to what he called traditional
Authority where Kings relied on folklore
and divinity to justify their power
then came the age of charismatic
authority where a heroic individual most
famously Napoleon could rise to power
with a magnetic personality and change
everything through passion and will
however Weber explained that we had now
entered a Third Age of bureaucratic
Authority bureaucracy achieves its power
via knowledge only the pure ik rats know
how stuff
works and it will take an outsider years
to work it out most of us simply give up
usefully for the powers that be the
dominance of bureaucracy has major
implications for anyone trying to change
a nation there is often an
understandable but misguided desire to
think that one just has to change the
leader but in fact removing a leader
almost never has the degree of impact
that is hoped for if we're to get things
to go better much of it will have to
come through outwardly rather undramatic
bureaucratic processes it will come
through the marshalling of statistical
evidence patient briefings to ministers
testimonies to committee hearings and a
minut study of budgets weber tells us
how power works now and reminds us that
ideas may be far more important than
tools or money in changing nations it's
a hugely significant thesis with vapers
guidance we learn that so much which we
associate with vast impersonal external
forces is in fact dependent upon
something utterly intimate and perhaps
more malleable the thoughts in our own
heads
you